[Music]  never judge a bull by its cover we're  finding out the biggest misconceptions  about our favorite stars at the  ferdinand la première people think they  got you all figured out based on how you  look I think over the years those  misconceptions are being shattered one  by one you know I do have a gold and  sometimes Stern exterior with the WWE  but moments like me proposing to Nicole  in front of 75,000 fans at WrestleMania  lets everybody know that yeah there's  there's times to be tough but this  you're never too ashamed to say you're  in love what is it about that moment  that just kind of brings tears to your  eyes that's the greatest love of my life  it was like worlds colliding WWE has  been my family for the last 15 years and  Nicole's the woman I want to spend the  rest of my life with it's it's the best  moment of my life  [Music]  you  [Music]